follow up on these apparently Wendy's
has a shortage I'm gonna call Nelson
Peltz he's no longer wise I like you and
they're ramping up okay basically you're
saying and we're gonna have you make
sure committees they want to be on the
financial committee or the Sports
Committee I've heard all of heard that's
all I do who I get calls from people the
biggest people they all want to be off
enemies of mine people that don't like
me want to be other committees I said
that's strange but they all want to do
it they all want to help so we're gonna
be announcing some very good names now
in this case you know we want
professional names that can help us not
just names will we put it on for the
status of the task force we don't need
status we need results
regarding sources of virus you suggest
that you receive some intelligence that
gave you some confidence today somehow
emanated from the Institute of virology
the Secretary of State on Sunday said
the same thing where are you now no
different no no I don't think there'll
be a big difference be a big difference
I think we know and I think you probably
know too
okay any other questions one followed by
China sir related to intelligence but
more specifically to how you will
respond to China you've talked about
tariffs would you like to put tariffs on
China as a punishment or would it be
more related to China not actually we're
in the midst of some very big things so
I just don't want to talk about that now
are you satisfied with China in terms of
how its fulfilling the trade deal phase
one I will be able to report on that the
end of next week they're buying a lot of
farm product but are they buying to the
level that they were supposed to you
know they're going to buy fifty billion
dollars worth the most they ever did was
fifteen or sixteen and now they're going
to 50 anywhere between 40 and 50 in
terms of form but 250 billion overall
that some that never happened no
president has ever even talked about
anything like that it's about time but
I'll I'll be able to report in about a
week or two as to not only with the
farmers but with many other industries
also okay
okay good I'd like to have it I'll
report them as they come in but we're
watching closely and you know they
understand have a deal hopefully they're
gonna keep the deal we'll see they may
they may not we're to find out we'll
know soon not only were the farm where
development and all already in storage
as you know with stockpiling we have
over 10,000 we've sent them to States
the states are old you have plenty of
ventilators right did you ever think
that was possible they never wrote a
story about it Kim no and that's a tough
word and Nigeria just called we're
giving them 250 ventilators we have many
countries I'd say 12 14 countries ago
we're sending quite a few to France
we're sending quite a few to Spain and
Italy and we have other countries we
have four African countries countries
located in Africa who are really in bad
shape frankly very bad shape and we're
sending them quite a few so we're in a
position where we can now help other
people because basically what do you
tell you're talking about people dying
you know it's not a question of
countries you're talking about a lot of
people are dying and we make a great
ventilator as you people found that your
people actually told me directly you
know if they're a good friend laters and
not so good we go top-of-the-line we're
making all top-of-the-line so we're
sending them to a lot of countries as
they need them and they they call
in in a certain way I like them to be
donations I really do I think it's
goodwill it's hard to say you have to
pay us in order to save people from
dying and I'm the first one to say you
got to pay but you know this is
something that's a little bit different
I think it's something they really
appreciate more than normally like you
know you're doing so you know like kind
of calls we've been getting there like
desperation calls because you can't make
him it takes you months and months to
get upset we did it in weeks
the people did an incredible job I was
very proud of them does not bring
something like this like since World War
two you know especially that because
praying for some linen or whatever it is
you a ventilator will save lives and
they always some of these countries have
done Larry I want us I mean you know it
calls
good question but we have many countries
calling and we're helping as many as we
can that this was the worst attack than
Pearl Harbor and 9/11 are you suggesting
that carbon 19 is actually I view the
invisible enemy as a war I don't like
how it got here because it could have
been stopped but no I view the invisible
enemy like a war Hey
it's killed more people than Pearl
Harbor and has killed more people than
the World Trade Center World Trade
Center was close to 3,000 well we're
gonna beat that by many times
unfortunately so yeah this we view it as
a war this is a mobilization against a
war it's in many ways it's a tougher
enemy you know we do very well against
the visible enemies it's the invisible
enemy this is an invisible enemy so but
we're doing a good job so I just heard
that I can only say this these were
young brilliant people that were brought
in because they have great expertise of
this people that love the country people
that
[Music]
and I think they helped us a lot on
ventilators I wasn't involved in that
but I think they helped us a lot
you know today to them they can look at
a ventilator and it's a very simple
machine somebody else looks at it they
have no clue I think they did an
incredible job now I don't know anything
about fact some of them were very rich
people with where the Selma company I
mean some people would say nerds okay
this is what they do and I think they
help things pricing but we were able to
get gowns and gloves and masks and all
these things at a very early point now
we're making a lot of you saw it
yesterday we were making masks at
Honeywell but I will say Debra you saw -
I mean the level of ramped up that we
did so quickly so I would say they did I
wasn't involved in the details but I can
tell you it started flowing that was the
with the planes pouring in or from all
over the place well I don't even know
that because I have no idea who who
bought I wasn't involved in that we have
a lot of support in our campaign a lot
of people are supporting our campaign
they want to see us win very badly so I
don't know do they have companies do
they not have companies I can tell you
these I don't believe these kids would
have any knowledge of any of these
companies any of these companies and you
know like I had seen this doctor bright
I never met dr. bright I don't know who
he is
I didn't hear good things about him I
did not hear good things about him at
all and to me he seems like a
disgruntled employee that's trying to
help the Democrats win an election by
getting out I mean he's got a pre-taped
sermon about you know what he thinks and
I can tell you they didn't think he did
a very particularly good job and
yes I didn't hear good things I did good
things a certain administration I mean
he certainly he certainly seemed to have
a very well packaged deal and he's got
the same lawyers at some other
well-known people had and he comes up
with the whistleblower I always thought
whistleblowers sort of a secret thing
well everyone knows who he is so what is
it a whistleblower will protect you from
what protects you from what when
everybody knows who he is because he was
very public about it and if you look at
his lawyers his lawyers are the same
lawyers that other people have used and
so I I don't know much about it but to
me he seems like a disgruntled employee
do you do you believe those figures well
I think what it is what it is from you
saying it's seventy thousand it's
approximately now seventy thousand so do
I believe them yeah I don't believe them
for China and I don't believe them from
other countries where I see you know a
very tiny number of people died but you
you're watching the news and you see
what's going on but our numbers are you
know essentially certified numbers their
individual hospitals they're putting out
the numbers I don't I don't imagine
there'd be a very big variation no it's
it's a big number but it's only touches
were see you know pain twenty thousand
that's if we did the big shut-ins and if
we went to the total shutdown and now
it's time to open up our country open up
our country okay thank you very much
everybody
you
[Music]
we're contacted by physicians who
alerted us to the importance of being
able to use this device potentially to
measure clapping and respiratory
activity
[Music]